thank you for all the love and support
thank you Dr Cook well the same day that
Jeff posted that David posted with his
friends who have all turned on Jeff and
they said we don't give a and it
was the same right after Jeff posted his
picture but Jeff seems pretty convinced
that this newest one was was intentional
it's like let's see there's more photos
they're celebrating they're drinking
They're laughing this right after Jeff
posted the picture of his eye well but
there's just now too much this is what
Jeff told me David's telling everybody
don't you can't talk to him you can
associate with him apparently even Jonah
was cut off like it's a cult
like he actually Cuts people off yeah so
check this out there's absolutely no way
this was just a coincidence a pick with
David one hour apart and then Jeff
posted this he said this was just
brought to my attention thanks for
expelling yourself you scumbags I wish I
knew this how you all felt when I kept
my mouth shut to try to protect this
piece put down the booze and get to
litigation